hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
design add and search words data
structure
so this is another problem from the
blind 75
leak code problems list so this is the
spreadsheet i've been using to track
which
uh videos we've uploaded for those 75
problems you can see that most of the
solutions have already been updated and
today we are working on this problem a
tree problem
add and search word so basically another
day another problem from the sleep code
blind 75 list the link
to this sheet will be in the description
if you do want to take a look
so basically we're designing a data
structure to efficiently solve this
problem
of basically adding words we're taking
new words
adding them to the data structure and
also we're being given words and we want
to search to see if those words
match any previously added words to our
data structure
so we only need to support three
functions for this data structure one is
just gonna be the constructor that's
gonna initialize the object one is gonna
be adding a word and that one is pretty
self-explanatory so we're just given a
string a word
and then we're adding it to the data
structure now this word could only
consist
of lowercase characters from lowercase a
to lowercase z
and the third one is going to be the one
where the bulk of the algorithm is going
to be contained so this is going to be
the searching
words so we're searching a word and the
word can contain
any character from lowercase a to
lowercase c but there's
one additional character it could
contain a dot
character and what we're told is that
the dot character is actually like a
wild card it can basically match
any character in the string so for
example let's say in our word
list so far let's say we had just a
string a
b right so this is what we have so far
and we're trying to search
dot b so basically would this search
match any words that contain so far in
our data structure the answer is yes
because the dot would match any first
character right so this
that we basically match this lowercase a
and then
we do have an additional b which matches
the second character
in the string so a dot matches any
character that's what's going to be
tricky for us
to implement now the brew force way to
solve this problem is pretty simple
right we would basically
have a list of words and then just
for every search we would just say okay
does this search match
any of the words in the input list now
that's not going to be super efficient
a more efficient solution is going to
require a try data structure
aka a prefix tree so this is what we're
going to be using to solve this problem
efficiently i will say if you've never
heard of this data structure
or you've never implemented it before
you basically don't have a chance of
solving this problem efficiently
but if you have heard of this data
structure it's pretty intuitive
why this data structure is used in this
problem basically
you know a prefix tree right so for
example if we were searching b
dot dot we would want to first find all
all words that start with the character
b
and then check you know are any of them
of length
two because the remaining portion of
this can match any string of length two
so a try is basically a tree that has
some kind of
root node and each node can have up to
26 children in this example because we
have lowercase characters from a
to z so basically each node is going to
represent a single character right and
then each node could have
up to 26 additional uh children
and basically a word in this case for
example you know this is
a if i had a b here and then another c
this is going to be a single word right
and
and so if we inserted the word let's say
we added the word
abc into our try this
is basically how it would look like now
one additional thing we have to say is
for a particular node such as c we have
to say
this is the end of the word right
because what we're trying to say is we
did not add the word
a we did not add the word a b we've only
added the word abc so we have to
designate that this is the last
character now if we added
another word for example a b what we're
going to do
we're not just going to repeat that
we're not just going to say okay now
there's going to be a lowercase a here
then there's going to be a lowercase b
notice how we already have those
characters available to us
we're going to reuse these characters so
instead what we would do adding
this word we would say okay let's add an
a so let's start at the root add an a we
see there's already an a that exists
then we'd say okay from here let's add a
b we see that a b
already exists so once we get
to the end of the word right that was
the last character then we just say okay
designate
this as an additional end of the word so
now we have two words
along this path we have one word a b we
have another word abc
notice how all words starting with an a
are going to be here right we could have
other words a
maybe a t or something right and other
words as well right
basically all words that start with a
are going to be here that's what makes
this
efficient that's why this is called a
prefix tree because
let's say we wanted all words starting
with
let's say we were searching something
like this right we're searching
a b dot dot so we want all words
for example or even one word of length
five
that starts with a b then we'd go okay
let's find a
then find b right here and then we'd go
through all possible children
that it has right in the tree we would
do a brute force depth first search
backtracking type approach
and then we'd get a word we would try to
find a word like this one
so with that being said let's run
through the example you can see at the
above the first word that we're going to
be adding is bad
so let's add a character for b
let's add a child for this a let's add a
child for it
d so now we've inserted the word bad
we do want to designate this as the end
of a word so i'll just mark it blue but
in our code obviously we're going to do
something different
next we're adding another word dad so
we have to start along a different path
because these two words have a different
prefix one starts with a b
one starts with a d so let's
additionally add a
and additionally add d once again
designating this as the end of a word
we're going to add one last word before
we start searching this one's going to
be mad
so we don't already have an m so we do
have to insert that and then we have to
insert a
and then d of course this is going to be
the end of a word so so far we have
three words all of them end with a d
but they all all three of them have
different prefixes that's why they're
along different paths
now let's get to the searching part the
interesting part so we're going to
search for a word pad now so what we're
going to do is we're going to start at
the beginning right
are there any words pad in this so first
we're going to try
are there any p's we're going to look is
there a p we don't see any right
we only have b d and m so we don't have
any words starting with a p
that means immediately we know false pad
does not exist in our input that's why
in the output over here you can see
false is what's returned next we're
searching another word that word is
going to be
bad so we're going to start at the root
and see are there any b's
we're going to see that yes we do have a
b over here
the next character in the string is a so
does this b have a child
a yes it does it has an a over here the
last character is a d
does this a have a child d yes it does
it's over here
now we yes we found the characters we
needed but now
lastly we have to say okay the last
character that in the
searching word is d is this in our try
is this designated as the end of a word
since it's marked blue
it is therefore we're going to return
true for this
uh input searching word and you can see
that's what's
written in the output this returns true
let's go through the last two search
examples so in this example we have
dot a d so what does that mean remember
the dot character means we can match
any character so we're going to start at
the root and we're going to go down
all three paths or or literally
any of the paths and to do that we're
going to have to use
depth first search or basically a
backtracking approach right
and remember we're only looking for one
word that matches this right so let's
say the first path we decide to go down
is this one right so this is a b
and we're allowed to use a b because the
dot matches any character so
this matches so far right next we're at
the next character
a does this path have a child a yes it
does
so we found another match next we're
looking for a d
does this have a child d yes it does and
it's designated as the end of a word so
in this case
we found one word that matches this and
that's all we need we just need one word
so we are going to return true
and you can see that up above now if
this one did not match for example if
this
wasn't designated as the end of a word
or maybe this was instead an
x character we would say okay we didn't
find a match down this path
but it doesn't matter because remember
the dot matches any character so
we don't have to go down this path let's
try going down this path right and we
would do the same thing we'd say okay we
have an
a we have a d that means we found a
match that means we can return
true and you can see that this is not
going to be
super efficient right we possibly we
would have to go through every single
character that's in
our try decision tree but it's still
more efficient than our brute force
approach
especially for this next last example so
we're doing
one last search and in this search we
have we start with a b
but then we have two dot characters and
the reason this is more efficient with a
try
rather than just brute forcing every
list because this
at least tells us okay we're starting
with a b so what we're gonna do in our
try decision trees we're gonna say okay
every other word that starts with
any other character than a b we're not
going to consider them and we have a
pretty small
try right now but it's possible we could
have a really big one right
so what this does for us is it
eliminates a lot of the possibilities
we say okay at least we know we're
starting with a b
and yes we did find a matching b so
we can go down this path now we get to
the brute force portion
where we have a dot right so basically
in this case it's simple because
we only have one child but maybe we'd
have multiple and then we'd have to go
down
all of those paths but in this case it's
simple right let's just check do we have
any
characters that go below it yes any
character will match this first dot now
we're looking for
another second dot do we have any
characters that match it yes
we have a d and it's the end of a word
so yes in this case
we also found a match so we can return
true just like we have up above
so once you can kind of understand this
visual example
it's not super hard now it's time to
actually implement the code and i'll
admit that it's actually a little tricky
but i'll go i'll try to guide you
through it
so one thing i like to do for try
problems is just define
a try node because it's going to have a
couple
uh variables so in the constructor we're
basically going to initialize
two fields so for this tri node we are
going to have
a list of children now i'm going to use
a hashmap for that
so basically what i'm going to say is
for each character we're going to say
something like you know a
is mapped to a tri node
and we could possibly do that for every
lowercase character from a to z
and for every character we also need to
designate if it's the end of a word so
i'm just going to use a boolean for that
call it word and initially we'll set it
to
false and so basically the only thing we
need to do for the constructor for the
constructor of the word dictionary is
just define a root so
let's call it root and it'll just be a
try note so initially you can see that
we don't have any characters
inserted right we just have an initial
empty try node
it doesn't have any children so no
characters are inserted
next we are going to do the add word
portion this portion isn't too difficult
so what we're gonna do
is we'll set current equal to what our
root is so self.root is
where we're gonna start and what we're
gonna do is basically go through every
single character
in the word and what we're gonna do is
we're gonna check
if this character is not already
inserted because it's possible this
character
could already be inserted in the try so
we're going to check if
if c is not in current
dot children because of the current
nodes children if c is not
in there then we we need to obviously
insert it right so what we would do is
say current.children
of c is going to be a new trinode
where we inserted a trinode
corresponding to the character c
and then of course what we're going to
do is we're going to update our current
pointer
to this uh new try node
if it didn't already exist that means we
just created it if it did already exist
then we just
shifted over to it right what we're
ultimately trying to do is insert
every character from this word into our
try and once
that's been completed what we're going
to do at the end
is say okay current dot word is now
going to be set to true
so we have created the characters and
designated this as
a word okay now for the actual meat and
potatoes of this problem
and this part is actually going to be
recursive and let me show you
why before we actually start doing the
recursive portion
so this is going to start similar to
what we had before right so current is
going to be initially set to
let's say self.root right and then what
we would want to do
is go through every single character in
the word in this case i'm actually going
to
use the index of the word and you'll see
why in a moment so
for i in range length of the word
and then we're going to get the
character at position i so word
of i and so remember this character
could be
any character from a to z in which case
the problem would be straightforward
right we would just search our try and
see does this character already exist
and then we'd continue if it doesn't
already exist then we would return false
but we know this character could
actually be a dot character that's
what's going to make this tricky so if c
equals a dot character the else
condition is if it is a regular
character
now let's start with the else case
because it's a little more simple so if
c
is just a regular character what are we
gonna do we're gonna check
if c is not in current.children that
means this character does not exist we
needed this character to exist we're
searching for this word but this
character does not exist
so what do we do then well simply we can
just return false that means we know for
sure this word does not exist
if it does exist then obviously we're
going to shift our current pointer
to that node so we're going to go to
current.children
at character c and then we would just
continue our algorithm right
but this case is going to be a little
bit more tricky because remember if the
character is a dot that means
potentially we're going down
26 different paths because this dot
could match
any of the 26 characters and we can't
really do that
iteratively very easily right we are
gonna use backtracking or recursion
to help us do that so for example let's
say we had a string like
dot a b what we would want to do then is
say okay
dot it could match any of the possible
characters so what we would say then is
we would go through for every
child in current dot children
dot values because remember for
current.children that's a hashmap
and then we want only the values because
those are going to be the actual
children
so because we know that dot could match
any character so for this
dot we would basically match every
single character and then we'd say okay
for each of these
we want to do the recursion on it so we
want to do
the depth first search on this and when
we're actually doing that depth for
search
it could just be an iterative matching
so what we're trying to what i'm trying
to get at is that this entire thing that
we just wrote
is the recursive function this is the
depth first search
right we have the iterative portion here
where we don't have a dot and we have
the recursive portion over here
where we do have a dot so let's wrap
this entire thing
inside of a depth first search function
depth first search dfs
and so let's just tab it over so now
let's think about it
when we're doing our depth first search
what are we going to pass
in well we want to know what's the
remaining portion of the word that we
are trying to match right so we would
want to pass in the
index so let's call that j we're passing
in the starting index
j right and the other thing we're
passing is what's the current
route that or the current node in our
try that we're at so
in this case if so depending on which
one of these we're iterating through
we're gonna pass in that child node
right so
so that's what the the node that we're
going to be passing in whatever child
that is
so that's how we're going to call dfs so
let's define that up above so j
is going to be uh the index parameter
and let's call root what the
node that we're passing in is so okay so
current is
instead of being called self.root it's
actually going to be initialized to the
root that we end up passing in
and okay so here i passed in j but we
would
what we would actually pass in is going
to be i actually not just i
i plus 1 because we're going down a
child
so we're going to pass in i plus 1
as the index of the character that we're
looking for
right because because what we're saying
is we're skipping the dot so we're going
to have to increment i plus
one and this function is going to return
a boolean so if this function
ends up returning true that means we
found one path that matches and remember
if we find a path that matches we return
true
immediately we're done we don't have to
do anything else if we don't find a path
we're going to keep going down all
possible paths
until we do if we never find a true if
we never find a match then we're going
to return
false oh and one more thing so initially
up above we said
i is going to go through range of the
length of the word but we know we could
be starting at a different position here
we're always going to start at zero we
don't want to do that we always want to
start at j whatever it happens to be
so that is the main recursive portion
and the last thing is let's say we were
given a word abc and let's say we found
a match right we didn't have any dots in
here what would that do
well we'd go through the for loop we'd
always execute the else condition
and we would always find the current
node and then the entire loop would be
finished then what would we want to
return out here
well we would want to return whatever
current happens to be
so if current dot word is true
then we would return true if
current.word was false
then we would return false so we can
just leave this
as it is so that's the main portion of
this algorithm the last thing that we
want to do
is actually call this step for search
function right so what are the
parameters that we're going to give it
well we're always going to start at
index 0 because we're going to start at
the beginning of the word so we can pass
in 0 for j
and we're always going to start at the
root node of our try so we can pass in
self.root
as the root node and then we would just
want to return the result that this dfs
function returns
so as you can see this function did work
and it does work pretty efficiently
so if you didn't already know what a try
was i hope that you learned that today
so this
is the entire code and if you did
already know what a try was i hope that
you learned a new application of it so i
hope this was helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully
see you pretty soon thanks for watching